My dad's first lesson to me was,
"Look people in the eye, mi hija,
make sure people see you
and you see them."
He has been a proud janitor,
farm worker, shoe shiner,
home builder and small business owner.
He has seen the world
from so many different lenses
and has lots of stories to tell.
But there's one I've never
been able to get out of my head.
A story when my dad was a young kid.
He and my tio Milo knew exactly
when the trucks would come in.
Under the freeway, just as the sun set,
they jumped the fence
to get into the dump.
And as they waited for the trucks,
they'd make bets on who would
find the best food.
An uneaten apple they could clean,
a perfect banana, sometimes
a candy bar or a wrapped sandwich.
And then they'd grab
whatever they could find,
and save the very best to bring home
to their even younger
brothers and sisters.
I hate that story.
But I share it
because we can't solve what we can't see.
In 1936,
this image of the migrant mother
captured the living
conditions in the West,
showing lawmakers
what people were going through.
After it published,
the United States government
sent 20,000 pounds of food,
and that image solidified support
for the very first safety-net
programs in America.
Yet still today, more than 37 million
Americans are still living in poverty.
One in six kids.
As a student of economics
and a career public servant,
I know we've been at this for a long time.
But it's my work today
that has given me the hope
that we can finally end
poverty as we know it.
And here's why.
Right now, there are 80
public benefit programs
all across the country,
intended to provide critical
anti-poverty resources.
Yet an estimated
60 billion dollars in benefits
go unclaimed every year.
Sixty billion.
I believe, in large part,
due to complicated,
outdated systems
that weren't designed
to see the people they serve.
I want you to imagine for a moment
that you lost your job,
and you don't know how you're going
to put food on the table.
But you hear about this government
program that can help.
And you begin the process of applying.
The first thing you realize is
you can't do it on the only online
connection you have, your phone,
because the only way to apply online
is through a desktop computer.
So you head to the community library,
you go through screen after screen,
answering close to 200 questions,
wading through confusing instructions.
It feels a little bit
like a game of gotcha,
except your benefits are at risk.
Now, if you're from a place
like my hometown,
a small rural farming town,
there isn't an easily accessible public
venue with desktop computers.
So you have to find a ride
to the nearest social services office,
maybe 30 miles away.
When you get there,
you have to walk through metal detectors
with two security guards,
past a long table of scattered paper forms
into the main waiting room.
It's loud, and there's a long line
leading to that service counter.
When you get to the front of it,
you're met with a thick,
clouded sheet of bulletproof glass
separating you from someone
who could finally help.
That has been the system in America
for many communities like mine.
So it's no wonder that 14 million
Americans aren't enrolled
in child and food nutrition programs,
or that six million are missing
health care benefits.
Technology has changed
almost every aspect of our lives.
It's made things faster,
more efficient, automatic.
We need to do the same
for people seeking benefits.
I work for an organization
called Code for America.
We deploy human-centered technology,
the kind that respects you from the start,
meets you where you are,
provides an easy, positive experience.
And our research has shown
there are four factors
we need to overcome.
First, we know that far more people
have access to the internet
on their phone than a desktop computer.
So applications should be online
and mobile-friendly.
Second, lots of people are falling off
because the process is complicated.
So applications need to be
simple and easy to use.
Third, we know that people
who are eligible for one program,
like food assistance,
are pretty likely to be eligible
for another, like health care.
So let's combine processes where we can.
And finally, we know there are unseen
heroes in government --
caseworkers, social workers --
on the front lines,
navigating old systems.
We can equip them with the data
and tools to streamline their efforts.
Here's what California's food
assistance used to look like.
183 questions, 51 pages of screens
available only by desktop computer.
We took that application
and redesigned it.
This is GetCalFresh,
a mobile-first application
available 24 hours a day
in multiple languages, with chat support.
(Applause)
California's food assistance application
went from one of the most
complex in the nation
to being recognized as one of the easiest
application experiences of any state.
For 10 years we had been working
with multiple states
on projects just like that,
showing the importance and potential
of digital delivery of benefits.
And that's when the pandemic hit.
And these images in West Valley, Utah;
San Antonio, Texas;
Pittsburgh, Pennsylvania.
Parking lots filled with families
waiting for food.
America could finally see
what we had been seeing for a decade.
The growing number of people in poverty
and communities left out
as a result of failing systems.
Our phone started ringing.
From Washington to Maryland,
we helped states distribute
600 million dollars in benefits
to kids in school lunch programs.
Louisiana used our best practices tools
in notifying people.
They proactively sent out more
than 40 million texts to residents
on how to access critical services.
And in Minnesota, we developed
an all-in-one application
for nine different safety-net benefits.
That can be completed
in less than 14 minutes.
(Applause)
Nearly 200,000 people immediately
applied in the first six months.
And for the first time ever,
Minnesota's system integrated to reach
all sovereign tribal nation members.
(Applause)
That's what is possible,
and this is the moment to keep going,
redesigning our safety net
for a new time and a new age.
And we can do it all across the country,
as governments reset.
Over the next seven years,
we will partner to redesign systems
to unlock 30 billion dollars in benefits
for 13 million eligible people
in at least 15 states.
We will bring data scientists
and engineers,
technologists and researchers together,
sitting side by side
with government teams.
And our Safety Net Innovation Lab will
improve upon and share best practices
so that every government can benefit.
Because at the heart of our audacious goal
is to show the world what’s possible
when we use the best tools we have today:
human-centered technology and government.
So that families aren’t waiting
in parking lots for resources.
Or kids,
growing up like my dad,
aren't searching for food
by whatever means possible.
Then, then we will see
the true potential of every kid.
And that's the calling of this moment
to redesign our systems
to see people, all people.
Thank you.
(Applause and cheers)